welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition this is a dimension
as vast as space and as timeless as
infinity it is the middle ground between
not seeing the show and seeing it it is
the channel where we explain it so you
don't have to this is the twilight zone
the show has just dropped its fifth
episode in the Jordan Peele reboot and
wunderkind is a modern commentary on
politics and society as a whole
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the episode and its ending this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen it yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now with that out the way
thanks for clicking the video now let's
dive into my ending explain breakdown of
the wunderkind The Twilight Zone reboot
has been pretty heavily criticized for
its social commentary being so
heavy-handed and it's almost hitting you
over the head with it and the wunderkind
is no different this is arguably the
episode that is most steeped in politics
so rather than do the typical recap I
thought I'd discuss the main themes of
it this could be a modern reboot of the
original series episode titled a good
life in which a young boy with godlike
powers ended up ruling over a town with
anger of a malevolent being the citizens
lived in fear of their leader and smiled
through gritted teeth as they were
forced about his every beckon call raft
throughout this episode finds himself in
the firing line of a child with immense
power and the two are tied together
quite heavily I definitely recommend
that you check that episode out as it's
one of the show's bests and it's clear
why they would choose to remake it the
wunderkind on the other hand follows
Rath Hanks as he awakens on an operating
table to find himself at the mercy of a
mysterious voice the episode tells the
tale of how he got there and follows his
career as a presidential campaign
manager that is attempting to put a
young YouTube sensation into the Oval
Office now from the AFT this is a very
clear commentary on Donald Trump's
presidential run
Trump was often criticized of being
childish and his Twitter rants have
given his critics a la
chin peel subverts this with the wind
akin and instead uses YouTube as
Oliver's outlet with this platform he is
able to reach millions and many people
just agree with what he's saying without
any backings of plans or statistics just
because it sounds good
sound familiar well this is basically
what would happen if Justin Bieber
became president and it's easy to see
how charisma goes a long way for
popularity when all of us starts stating
things like more jobs more air to
breathe he quickly becomes popular and
hanks helps him to implement his
campaign throughout the country free
video games for Oliver also seems to be
his biggest promise and this seems to be
a direct retort to the political claims
that games cause things like mass
shootings and more clearly the creative
team behind this are trying to show that
any aspect can be weaponized in a
political campaign to fit agendas and it
showcases how people get swept up in
statements instead of looking at the
practicality behind them
Oliver stumbles through debates knows
little of foreign policy and yet people
still love him so why is this well
perhaps it's because there's no filter
in place as much as you can disagree
with Trump even his staunchest critics
must realize that he won because he's
not a standard politician and doesn't
feel like a puppet
Oliver too embodies this with his
outbursts and groundedness the episode
suggests that Trump came along at a time
when people were so disillusioned with
politics that anyone could have be
plunked in front of the camera and would
at one people are just so apathetic to
the entire thing that they will vote for
whoever promises the most therefore what
this episode is really suggesting is
that people need to stop being so
apathetic towards politics in order to
take back the country and stop us from
all ending up in similar positions to
the one that Raph finds himself in
Oliver of course gets elected and put in
the Oval Office but it's clear that he's
out of his depth and has been spoiled by
the gain in power he begins by bringing
three video games to everyone and
similar to Trump he tries to bypass
Congress in order to fulfill his
campaign promises there are several
outbursts which are obviously comments
on Trump's personality and gradually the
country falls apart
Oliver enforces and no old doctors
policy and this of course leads to the
position ruff finds himself in at the
end after being accused of treason
Oliver turns on his
and he is shot Rapha survives it but
unfortunately he finds himself being
operated on by a child who doesn't want
to do anything more than get back to
playing video games and therefore rap
gets a fate of his own doing now whilst
the episode may be pretty heavy-handed
in its trump metaphors there's also the
possibility that this could indeed be
aimed at liberals who perhaps don't have
the wisdom that comes with age to
properly see politics for what they are
there for the episode could be viewed as
what may happen should the decisions be
handed over to those perhaps too young
to see the outcomes and I do appreciate
that there is duality to the episode
even if I feel that it fails to really
live up to its premise overall this is
another mixed bag for the series with a
getting too bogged down in its own
ideologies to deliver an enjoyable
narrative for me if more time was spent
on character development instead of
setting up subtext I think this could be
in a similar vein to Black Mirror but it
falls short so many times what was so
good about the original series is that
its episodes were enjoyable whether you
knew the subtext behind them or not
peels version seems like you have to be
aware of several aspects of modern
society in order to even scratch the
surface and this makes them slightly and
accessible overall as we head into the
final episode of the show I'm not too
excited but I guess we'll find out if it
lives up to the hybrid next week
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and if you're enjoying
the series so far comment below and let
me know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the entire season
thus far which would be linked at the
end this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to Definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]
[Music]